un grupo funcional es un grupo de átomos
que tiene un comportamiento químico
predecible existen muchos grupos
funcionales en química orgánica veamos
algunos empecemos con él al que no él al
que no tiene un doble enlace entre dos
carbonos r se refiere al resto del
compuesto que generalmente son carbonos
e hidrógeno del lado derecho tenemos un
ejemplo esta molécula contiene un doble
enlace como le llamaremos bueno si
tenemos un arcano de 4 carbonos lo
dibujaré por aquí 1 2 3 y 4
a esto se le conoce como butano
butano como nosotros tenemos un al que
no también de 4 carbonos solo
necesitamos cambiar la terminación de
alcano por la de al que no entonces el
nombre de esta molécula es voten voten y
para enumerar los carbonos empezamos con
el doble enlace
este es el carbono 1 carbono 2 carbono 3
y carbono 4 el doble enlace empieza en
el carbono 1 así que tenemos al 1 bote
no veamos otro ejemplo de un al que no
si tenemos un anillo a este compuesto le
llamamos ciclohexano pero qué pasa si
ponemos un doble enlace
ahora tenemos ciclo exc no observen que
hay un doble enlace carbono carbono al
igual que en esta molécula
2 tienen un grupo funcional al que no
por lo tanto estas dos moléculas podrán
reaccionar por los mismos tipos de
reacciones tienen un comportamiento
químico predecible y esa es la utilidad
de identificar a los grupos funcionales
el siguiente ejemplo de un grupo
funcional es el alc y no tenemos un
triple enlace entre dos carbonos si
observamos el ejemplo del lado derecho
este es el carbono 1 2
y 4 al dibujar un alquilo esta parte de
la molécula hace que sea lineal entonces
tenemos 4 carbonos y para nombrarlo
usamos el prefijo wood y la terminación
del al 'chino' así que este es el
bottino bottino y nuestro triple enlace
empieza en el carbono 2 así que el
nombre iupac es 2 wood y no ahora
echemos un vistazo al arena o también
llamado anillo aromático consiste en un
anillo de 6 carbonos con dobles enlaces
alternados es decir con tres dobles
enlaces pero no porque tenga dobles
enlaces significa que es un al que no en
realidad los arenosos reaccionan muy
diferente a los al que nos por eso se
considera como un grupo funcional
diferente
del lado derecho tenemos un ejemplo del
harén o anillo aromático esta parte de
la molécula corresponde a un benceno que
es muy famoso en química orgánica y por
acá tenemos un grupo metilo saliendo del
anillo de benceno un nombre para esto
sería metil benceno aunque no es tan
común encontrarlo así generalmente a
esta molécula se le conoce como tolueno
entonces el tolueno es un ejemplo de
arenós y reaccionará de manera similar
al benceno nuestro siguiente grupo
funcional es una luro de alquilo al 1 se
refiere a los halógenos x puede ser un
halógeno como cloro y bromo y r
corresponde al grupo alquilo para el
ejemplo de la derecha nuestro halógeno
es
y nuestro grupo alquiló es un grupo
estilo tenemos un h2 y h3 así que esta
molécula es cloruro de etilo aunque
también se le conoce como cloro eta no
nuestro siguiente grupo funcional es un
alcohol un alcohol consiste en un bache
y una r para el resto de la molécula en
nuestro ejemplo tenemos un h o grupo
hidroxilo y luego tenemos un ch todos y
ch 3 tenemos 2 carbonos en esta molécula
así que usamos el prefijo ed y como es
un alcohol el nombre completo para esta
molécula sería etanol una molécula muy
famosa
ahora veamos el éter éter tiene un
oxígeno unido a dos grupos r grupo r y
grupo r estos grupos r pueden ser los
mismos o diferentes en el ejemplo de la
derecha los grupos son iguales aquí
tenemos al oxígeno este es un grupo r y
grupo r
los dos grupos r son grupos estilo así
que a esto le llamamos dietil éter que
es el éter más famoso muchas veces se le
conoce solamente como éter pero dietil
éter es una forma de nombrar a esta
molécula ahora echemos un vistazo al tío
el tío es muy parecido al alcohol pero
en lugar de un h tenemos un
es decir azufre en lugar de un oxígeno
en nuestro ejemplo de ti hoy tenemos un
sh y un grupo estilo entonces un nombre
para esto podría ser esta noción gitano
de hoy a continuación tenemos al sulfuro
un sulfuro es muy parecido al éter en el
éter tenemos r&r y para el sulfuro
tenemos r&s r
en nuestro ejemplo de la derecha tenemos
al azufre y dos grupos estilo así que le
podemos llamar dietil sulfuro dietil
sulfuro y finalmente para este vídeo
nuestro último grupo funcional es una
mina en una mina tenemos un nitrógeno
unido a tres grupos r
que también pueden ser hidrógenos
cualquiera de estos grupos puede ser un
hidrógeno en nuestro ejemplo de amina
tenemos un nitrógeno con un par de
electrones libres dos grupos estilo y un
hidrógeno así que un nombre para esto
sería 10.000 amina dietil
a mí me veremos más grupos funcionales
en el siguiente vídeo